Now we're going to move on to just a couple of talks about various tools that you will be utilizing for gameplay code and systems code
that are kind of good to be aware of that don't really fit tidily into any of those previous brackets.
So first off we have delegates and events.
First thing we should talk about is what actually is a delegate.
This might be a kind of term and concept that you're already familiar with, especially if you've worked in C sharp because they've got them there.
But if you're not aware of them, delegates are essentially a type that can reference and execute member functions on objects.
So if you imagine a type that maintains an array of function pointers and it can maintain a reference to either a single function pointer or a set of them
and then you can execute those functions from a single location, that's essentially what it is.
It's an implementation of what would be called in formal terms the observer pattern.
It's important to highlight one of the great powers and uses for these things is these delegates can be bound dynamically at runtime
so you can change the functions that will get called back from a delegate.
A classic example would be a switch in a video game.
You as a designer might want a switch to open a door and then maybe one time you want to reuse that switch and have it turn on a light.
And so if you do that by a delegate you're not having to really tightly couple these systems together.
The light doesn't have to know or the switch doesn't have to know that it's going to be used on a light and a door.
The switch just knows I'm telling people that I've been switched on and it's the people who are registering to that event that need to know about the light.
Delegates are also safe to copy around.
You can pass them around by value but it will allocate memory on the heap when you do this.
So when possible, when it's not too difficult, passing by reference is probably a little bit more memory efficient.
So there's a whole set of delegates available to us in Unreal.
The key ones to highlight is we have the concept of single versus multicast.
So single is a one-to-one binding.
You can only bind one function into this delegate at a time.
If you want to have a new function you need to remove the old one.
Multicast is kind of one-to-many bindings.
So three, four, twenty functions could all link themselves, bind themselves to this one delegate.
And when that delegate fires, all of those functions will get executed one after another.
And then we have the concept of dynamic.
There are both dynamic single and dynamic multicast delegates.
And dynamic essentially represents that they are available to the reflection system for a start.
So dynamic delegates can only be used on UObject and downwards types.
So ones that are kind of part of the Unreal ecosystem.
And they, particularly multicast dynamic delegates, can be exposed to Blueprints.
So that's one of the great uses for dynamic delegates.
Dynamic delegates are also serializable, meaning we can save them more easily.
The kind of one that is something to bear in mind about dynamic versus non-dynamic is that dynamic do tend to be slower.
So they're less kind of performant.
And we have more capabilities available to us if we choose non-dynamic.
So we can bind lambdas, we can bind function pointers to non-UObject types.
And we can also use payloads, which we can't use for dynamic delegates.
Which we'll get into a little bit more in a bit.
There is also the concept of events.
This is a kind of specialized type of delegate where the execution of that delegate is restricted to a particular class.
So that delegate is owned by a particular class, its execution can only be fired by the class that owns that delegate.
This still exists in code, but it's just worth mentioning that whilst it still exists and you can use it,
actually that rule about only being owned by this particular type isn't actually strictly enforced.
So from 4.2.6 onwards, it's deemed as essentially deprecated.
So you might still find them referenced occasionally and used,
but actually for the express purpose for which they're intended, it's not actually forced.
You could kind of break that.
So just some demonstrations for a single non-dynamic delegate.
This is how it would look.
Every time we declare a delegate, it would be in a format similar to this.
So we'll get onto this in the following page with the other examples.
You'll see this is kind of in common.
These declarations always come with a declare underscore, it's a macro.
So declare delegate.
Retval here means this is a delegate that can return a value,
which is only applicable for single delegates because obviously if you had a multicast,
if five items bind to this delegate,
how would you know which of those five return values you're going to use?
So retval is only relevant when you're doing a non-multicast delegate.
And one param means that this delegate takes one parameter.
All forms of delegates can take up to, I think it's nine parameters they can have.
There's a header you can actually look into, which is delegate combinations, I think it is,
where you can just see all the different versions, iterations of this macro.
But yeah, ultimately they can name conventions the same.
So once you've written one, you'll kind of know how the rest are written.
So what this does is this defines a signature for that delegate.
And then we define an instance of that delegate to actually bind to and to broadcast from.
So this is defining the signature, and then this is the actual delegate that we're talking about.
And then in terms of actually using that delegate, this is an example of the code we might have.
So the kind of key things to highlight here is that because this is a non-dynamic delegate,
again, we can bind to non-U object types.
So I've just created a temporary instance of this F some non-U object class
using shared pointers here, which we talked about in a previous session.
And this is just a little example of what that class actually looks like.
So you can see we've just got this one function. It's really not very interesting class.
It's just a kind of very minimal implementation.
This function does need to be public so that we can bind to it.
But if we look, the delegate says it's a one parameter delegate.
And it's got a return value of int32 here we specified.
So this function does return an int32, but it takes two parameters.
So the reason that this is okay, the reason that you combine this function
is because we're using something called payloads.
So payload is essentially an ability to bind additional data to a delegate at bind time.
So our delegate signature says it takes in one parameter.
But if we want to bind to a function that takes additional parameters,
we just need to say, and for those additional parameters, here's the data to feed into those.
So at the point that we bind that function to that delegate,
we're specifying what that additional data would be.
So in this case, when we actually finally execute that delegate,
which is what we're doing here, you can see because it has a return value,
we can feed that value back into a variable and do whatever we want with that.
We only execute and pass in the one variable that we specify here.
This is our one parameter.
But the other value that's going to be fed into this some other float
has already been specified at the bind, and that's going to be this number seven.
So when this function gets executed, it's going to receive 0.2 as infloat,
and it's going to receive 7.0 as some other float.
And then we can do whatever we want with that.
The kind of things to mention here is that particularly when you're doing return values,
we need to be sure that this delegate actually has something bound to it,
so that's what this is bound is for.
And when you're binding raw, when you're doing things that aren't UObjects,
so we can't count on the fact that they're going to be properly garbage collected and cleaned up,
when you're binding raw functions,
it's possible that objects get deleted before you execute the delegate,
which would cause a crash, and there's nothing protecting us from that.
So you need to be quite diligent with making sure that when this object is getting destroyed,
you make sure it unbinds from any delegates that it might be bound to.
So then we move on to multicast.
This is also the example of non-dynamic.
So multicast, again, is our kind of one-to-many binding.
Naming convention looks pretty similar.
As you can see, declare multicast delegate and then our number of params.
We don't have retval because multicast delegates can't return a return value.
But the kind of thing I wanted to highlight here was,
as you can see, we've got a delegate signature name,
and then we have our two parameters, so this takes a bool and a UObject pointer.
Now, this is defining a signature,
but multiple instances could reuse that same signature,
and you will see this in Unreal code sometimes,
that we declare a signature once,
and then you reuse that signature for different occasions.
So you could imagine some situation where,
if really all that we care about is what input parameters it takes,
we don't need to do two, three, four different delegate declarations
if we're going to have several types that essentially take the same input parameters.
So we have an onHit object and an onDamagedBy object that both have the same signature,
so we can reuse that delegate signature,
even though these are different delegate instances
and can be bound to independently.
So when it actually comes to using this in code,
the key things I wanted to highlight here is that
when we are binding to a multicast delegate,
rather than using the term bind, we use add,
because that's the concept, right?
It's almost like an array of functions that it would call back to,
so we use the term add.
And because, again, this is non-dynamic,
we have the ability to use lambdas.
So for anyone who's not familiar with lambdas,
that's also referred to as anonymous functions.
It's just kind of like writing a function in line.
So this is, I'm not going to go into detail about these things,
but essentially this is, the body of this function would be,
this isn't a function that's defined somewhere else in the class,
it's defined here in line inside our body.
And again, because it's multicast, we can add an additional function,
and addUObject is the kind of simplest way
to add a reference to a function that is part of a UObject,
so a non-raw object,
and then that means it's going to be automatically garbage collected
and it's a little bit safer.
If you try and bind a raw function to an object
that is actually a UObject or inherits from that chain,
so in this case, this is our actor which inherits from object,
you'll actually get told off by the compiler,
so it won't actually let you do that.
So you have to use addUObject if it's a UObject type or downwards.
And then you can just see here,
we just declared a null value just to kind of have some parameter
to feed in to this delegate.
And we can perform that same check here for isBound,
it's not necessary, but it's tidy.
And then instead of execute,
we use the term broadcast for multicast delegates
because that's kind of more indicative of what it's doing,
it's letting possibly several things know,
it's broadcasting this information.
And then last of all, we actually have the dynamic delegates.
Like I said, you can have non-multicast dynamic delegates,
but if you want this to be exposed to Blueprint,
it does need to be multicast.
So whenever you make a delegate,
or I think they're called event dispatches in Blueprint,
that is always a multicast dynamic delegate.
So this is what that syntax would look like,
very, very similar to the previous ones, as you can see,
but it's declared dynamic, then multicast,
or we wouldn't have multicast there if it was a single one,
declared dynamic multicast delegate,
and then our number of prams.
Again, because this is multicast,
it can't have a return value.
If you do want to expose it to Blueprint,
it does have to be dynamic multicast,
but also you need this additional metadata
above your delegate instance.
So in this case, you property,
because even though delegates kind of call two functions,
they are actually properties, they are data,
and you use this blueprint assignable.
If we didn't have this above our delegate instance,
then it wouldn't be visible to Blueprint.
Then in terms of actually binding and using it,
we have very similar functions
to our previous non-dynamic multicasts,
where it's using the term add,
and then it's add dynamic.
So we can use add dynamic or add unique dynamic
if you want to make sure
that you haven't already bound this function.
When you're typing this in,
it's just worth highlighting that actually sometimes
your IDE will kind of do some weird things
where it says it can't find the function,
but if you just type add unique dynamic,
it will actually realize that that's okay.
It might try and prompt you to preface it
with some underscores, but that's not necessary.
And then otherwise, it looked pretty much the same
as our U object bindings,
where we just specified the object
that the function is getting called on,
and then which function we're actually binding to.
Obviously, this function signature
needs to match the signature of our delegate
as the case with all the others.
As I mentioned previously,
we can't use payloads here,
so we can't use bind time data
to make functions
that don't actually have the same signature
match our delegate signature,
so just worth bearing that in mind.
And then we have these same checks available to us
where we can check whether or not
that delegate has anything bound to it
and then that same terminology broadcast for our value.
Now, we don't have to bind Blueprint functions
to this delegate.
We can also bind C++ functions,
but the thing that's worth highlighting about that
is that if it's a dynamic delegate,
that function has to have a U function metadata on it.
If you tried to bind a function
to a dynamic delegate without U function,
it would probably not cause a compile error,
but when you go to broadcast that,
it would tell you off,
so that's just something to bear in mind.
And then last of all,
this is just what it would look like in Blueprint.
The one thing I haven't actually touched on here
is that with our delegate signature declaration,
with dynamic delegates, you specify for each parameter,
you specify the parameter type,
and then also a default name for that parameter.
And that's not relevant here.
You can see these names don't match up.
In C++, you can call it whatever you like,
but in Blueprint, if you go to bind to that delegate,
automatically it will use this default name
as your parameter name.
So I have not typed that in.
I just dragged off this event and typed custom event
and it auto-generated this
and it used float parameter name
as the default name for that parameter.
So that's the kind of difference
that you'll notice between delegate signature declarations
is with non-dynamics,
you don't specify a name per parameter,
but for dynamic delegates,
you do have to do an additional argument
that is a name for each parameter.
So if this were two parameters,
it would be float, float param name,
bool, bool param name or whatever.
So that about wraps it up for delegates.